you've probably heard about Sarah Jong
she's an asian-american reporter who was
just hired by the New York Times and she
after being hired some old tweets of
hers resurfaced lots of tweets where she
is blatantly racist and sexist she
repeatedly insults white people and men
she compares white people to goblins she
says that she enjoys being cruel to old
white men she compares white people to
to dogs she calls them all kinds of
names and on and on and on and on in
there there's their ton of tweets like
this not just a few but it's like quite
quite a bit and the times a sticking by
her they're not gonna fire her the left
has defended her tweets and her and the
decision not to fire based on the idea
that she can't possibly be racist even
when she is racist because she's not
white and only white people can be
racist
and we'll talk about that in a minute
but we must first admit that it's it's
actually not exactly accurate to say
that these tweets resurfaced okay it's
not like they were at the bottom of the
ocean and they happened to float to the
top and people said Oh what are these
racist tweets floating here let's take a
look no they were they were more like
excavated by people on the right who
were looking for another head on the
trophy case so they they went and they
they dug up these tweets they went
searching for them and they were dug up
by the Wrights own outraged mob you see
that both sides have an outraged mob now
and both outraged mobs operate the same
way they both are just constantly
looking for reasons to be outraged and
they kind of take turns being outraged
if it's it seems like it's almost
planned I don't know if they get
together and they say okay it's your
turn to be outraged now it's my turn I'm
not sure but they kind of take turns
being outraged or pretending to be
outraged by things every once in a blue
moon you'll see and it's very inspiring
to see this where the outraged mobs can
come together and pretend to be outraged
by the same thing every once awhile that
happens but usually it's um it's a kind
of back-and-forth thing and it's you
know the outraged mob in modern America
is very different from the classic
pitchfork mob that maybe you would have
seen in like the 18th century or
something like that
where the villagers would actually grab
pitchforks and they were because they
were upset by something or other it's a
similar kind of thing happens now but
here's the difference
the modern outraged mob when when you
look at them grabbing the pitchforks and
you look at the expression on their face
they're all super happy they're so happy
to be outraged so they're grabbing the
pitchforks and they're going
we're so outraged oh my gosh we're
outraged hey everybody let's be outraged
we have a reason to be outraged we found
a reason another one yes we're outraged
so that's what they're doing they are
they're so happy to be outraged they're
not actually outraged at all they're
just they're so it's um it's almost kind
of sweet really I I wish that I could
ever be as happy about something as the
rage mob is about about their their
reasons to be outraged outraged makes
them so happy and I think this is part
of the reason why the New York Times has
decided not to fire Sara Jang because
they realize that all the people who are
pretending to be upset aren't really
upset so there's no reason to take them
seriously and also probably 95% of them
are not near time subscribers so what
they have nothing to really hold over
your head they can't do anything to you
and this is what I say to any time this
happens where you know someone is is an
employee of a company is the target of
the outraged mob and the outraged mob
tries to get them fired from the company
I always say to the company whatever the
whoever the company is like there's no
reason to respond to this these people
are not really upset they're not they
don't actually care at all about this
they're really happy actually so there's
no reason to take their outrage
seriously obviously these tweets are
100% completely racist but
I'm not a fan of this thing that we're
doing now where both sides are only
interested in personally destroying
members of the other side
and I'm especially not a fan of it
because it's so disingenuous and
everyone knows it yet we're all taking
part in like this game and we all know
it's a game we all know that no one
cares about any of this stuff really yes
Sara Jong is definitely racist but I
don't care do you really care about that
nobody cares I don't even know which I
didn't know who she was
up until three days ago now we're all
supposed to catch oh my gosh this random
person said racist things I'm so upset
no I'm not upset
neither you nobody cares no one cares I
think as conservatives we really have to
decide if we want to be right not just
on the right we do we want to be right
or do we want to score points in this
weird bizarre game that we're playing
and if we want to be right then we can't
behave exactly as the Left behaves
the problem is that now when the leftist
outrage mob comes for someone the right
can no longer sermonize about how the
left hates free speech and it weaponize
his outrage and so on and so on and so
on because the right does exactly the
same thing and you want to talk about
scoring points it used to be the
outraged mob thing up until I don't know
the last couple years the outraged mob
phenomenon in modern America used to be
kind of an exclusively left-wing
phenomenon so um and that was a really
good point that the right could make to
our own benefit we could say look how
they look what they do you know they
they hate free speech they don't they
don't want anyone to express their views
they weaponize outrage they tried they
they just started personally destroy and
shut people down their disingenuous that
dishonest about it and I think that that
was a very powerful point that we could
make and I think it caused a lot of
people maybe not to come over to the
right but it caused a lot of people to
shy away from the left and say I don't
want any part of that because that's not
who I am I don't want to do that you
know I'm not into that
and so it was a very powerful thing we
had in our corner that now we've lost
because we're doing the exact same thing
look I'll admit this okay I like being
right I really enjoy it I'm not saying I
like being on the right because I don't
see much of a difference between the two
sides anymore I just like being right I
want to be right I really do I just I I
much prefer to be right
I hate being wrong I'd prefer to be
right and that's why I really it's just
it's so sad to me that the right has
decided to stop being right in our
effort to defeat the left we've become
just like them which is really the
opposite of defeating them the whole
point of the cultural war is to decide
whose philosophy whose vision whose way
of doing things is going to define the
culture well clearly the left has won
that battle because everybody has
adopted the left of vision and method
and philosophy there's no competition
anymore everyone's on the left now it's
just a battle for control between two
leftist factions between two factions of
morally relativistic ends justify the
means
disingenuous people just two factions of
that same type of thing
and to me that's very sad all right so
that's that but what about the racism
expressed by John
well we're told as I said that she can't
be racist because she isn't white
she doesn't have institutional power
we're told therefore she can't be racist
a democratic operative was on CNN last
night Symone Sanders is a name she was
on CNN last night and she said that John
is is not and cannot be racist because
racism is prejudice plus power and
that's the definition of racism that the
left has been using for decades
where did they get this definition from
um well this was a definition of racism
that was first invented out of whole
cloth by an obscure leftist in 1970 her
name is Patricia Badal and she wrote a
book published in 1970 titled developing
new perspectives on race an innovative
multimedia social studies curriculum in
racism awareness for the secondary level
classic book I'm sure we've all read it
right well that's the first time that
this definition of racism this idea that
racism is is is prejudice plus power and
so you can't be racist unless you also
have institutional power this was
invented by Patricia Badal so anytime he
left this uses this definition and you
ask him where they got it from if they
know what they're talking about and
they're honest they would have to say
well Patricia but dole said it that's
how we know it
I mean if Patricia Badal said it that it
must be true right Patricia Badal I mean
she has so Patricia Bedok decided to
define a square as a shape with three
sides
well then geometry must change because
Patricia Badal has has decreed it from
on high
it's ridiculous of course she made up
this definition put it up in a book and
the left has ever since pretended that
the meaning of the word has inherently
changed because Patricia Badal said so
but there are a few problems with this
definition okay let's go through them
one by one number one well as we've
covered it's completely and totally made
up and that to me is a problem the
dictionary definition of racism from
Webster goes like this a belief that
race is the primary determinant of human
traits and capacities and that racial
differences produce an inherent
superiority or inferiority of course of
a particular race
now there's nothing in there about power
or institutions or anything because that
has no bearing on the meaning of the
word it's irrelevant
that's what racism is so you have what
the dictionary says verse what some
random left is said in 1970 which is the
more authoritative source here number
two this definition
absolves people of racism
on the basis that their racism is
warranted so it says that a black person
can't be racist essentially because a
black person has every reason to hate
white people given that he's been the
victim of historical oppression and so
on
but that just means that the left is
guilty of racism even in defining racism
it says that white people deserve to be
hated
that's essentially their definition of
racism which is racist so they have
injected racism into the definition of
racism which is kind of interesting
number three the left notion of racism
is grounded in this really ridiculous
idea of what constitutes institutional
power so they have arbitrarily connected
racism to institutional power and said
that in order for it to be racist it
depends on this idea of institutional
power now that in itself is nonsensical
but then they take it a step further and
they have defined institutional power in
a way that is also nonsensical so this
we have two levels of nonsense to cut
through here
they say that institutional power is by
definition white and all white people
benefit from it and all white people
have more institutional power than all
black people
this is obviously madness because it
would mean that Barack Obama when he was
president of the United States and the
most powerful man in the world had less
institutional power than me it would
mean that Oprah Winfrey has less
institutional power than a white guy in
a trailer park so if Oprah Winfrey went
to a trailer park
and took out a megaphone and just
started shouting anti white racial slurs
into it at all the people in the trailer
park
it would not be racist because all of
those people in the trailer park have
more power than a billionaire celebrity
that's according to the left that's the
way it goes
which is idiotic obviously number four
this idea of racism removes
and this is really the point it removes
all individuality and turns people into
just sort of faceless representatives of
their race and it causes us all to kind
of fade into the collective which is
always the left same of course and
that's how you can argue that Obama has
less institutional power than some
random white dude and Oprah has less
institutional power than a guy in a
trailer and Eric Holder when he was
running the DOJ had less institutional
power than a beat cop in Charleston West
Virginia or even like if you work for a
fortune 500 company and you're an intern
working in the mailroom and you're white
you have more institutional power than
the black CEO of the company that's what
that's the way I go or if you're let's
say you're at you're a white guy in
prison and a black guy Issel is the
warden of the prison you have more power
in the jail cell than the guy who's
running the prison this is the left side
eeeh of its it's an idea so crazy so
stupid so self-evidently nonsensical
that you can't even it you can hardly
even dissect it you can hardly even
debunk it because it's so insane that
there's nothing it's like either you
realize just by looking at it how crazy
this is or there's nothing I can do for
you
but
but how does this work I mean how can
they draw this conclusion
well it's because they see Oprah and
Eric Holder and Obama and the black
prison warden and the black CEO they see
them not as individual human beings but
as black people that's all they're just
black people
Oprah is not Oprah she's just black and
the white person is not a person not an
individual
he's just a representative of whiteness
that's all so although Oprah is a
billionaire and one of the most powerful
people in the world she has less power
than she has less power than a guy -
trailer park because she's a non
individual she's a non human from the
leftist perspective from the
collectivist mentality of the left
Oprah is kind of just sort of a a vessel
of blackness she's not a she's not a
person she is a vessel of blackness and
the white guy in the trailer park is not
a person he's a vessel of whiteness and
so when you compare the two you have you
don't have Jim Bob in the trailer park
verse Oprah the billionaire celebrity
you have a vessel of blackness versus a
vessel of whiteness and whiteness always
is more powerful and therefore blackness
can never be racist ed white ed
whiteness this is how the left sees all
of us
by the way vessel of whiteness will be a
great name for for a band or vessel the
blackness really either one of them it
sob it's dehumanizing it's deranged
and it's also racist in and of itself
because remember that the the the the
Webster dictionary definition of racism
is to see raced race as the primary
determinant of a person's traits and
characteristics and that's exactly what
the Left does so they're their
definition of racism and their ways of
looking at race are themselves racist
fifth thing notice the circular logic
here so the left constantly blames white
people for being racist and accuses us
of being the only racists in the country
while at the same time claiming that by
definition through no fault of our own
individually we're the only ones who can
be racist and we're all racist just by
virtue of our skin color no matter
matter what we think individually so
they say stop being racist and then they
say you're you're an inherent racist
so you're inherently racist
therefore you are racist therefore will
cut you down and castigate you for being
racist
but then we go back to the beginning you
have no choice but to be raises because
you're inherently raised so you see how
the circle works here where are they on
one hand they're not it's it's they're
essentially saying it's no fault of your
own that you're racist because it's just
it's just you were born that way and
then you're there but on the other hand
they still want to blame you for it and
and cut you down and use it as evidence
of your lack of moral character and so
on and so forth
so that's how I go I mean what I'm
saying is if the left took their own
definition of racism seriously
then they could never get mad at a
racist person
if you're taking it serious if that's
really what you believe you you have no
reason to ever be mad at a racist person
because by your definition he has no
choice it is not a choice that he made
individually it came with his skin color
and he has no choice in the matter
so by that way of thinking it you'd
almost have to feel sorry for a racist
person it's like a disease that he
inherited it's not his fault you should
feel sorry for him he's a victim really
of his own racism last point here number
six
I'm not gonna spend a lot of time on
this I think I just think it's it's
important to note that when we talk
about institutional discrimination for
the most part institutional
discrimination is is is certainly not
legal in the United States anymore and
for the most part it doesn't exist in
any legal official capacity but there is
one form of official and legal
institutional discrimination there's
only one form I can think of it still
exists in America and that is
affirmative action that is the
definition of institutional
discrimination it is an institutional
policy to discriminate against white
people especially white men
so really if institutional
discrimination is the is the determining
factor for racism then actually by that
logic you could argue that white people
are the only ones who can't be racist
because we're the only ones who
officially legally can still be a
subject of institutional discrimination
so I mean I could give you 15 or 16 more
reasons why this whole idea of racism is
absurd but I think that's enough and
we'll just leave it there thanks for
watching everybody
Godspeed